nieto costa's reimagining of 1992's
candyman is a faithful modernization of
the cult horror classic co-written with
jordan peele the film is a fitting
tribute to the original especially by
the time it reaches its end we've got
everything you need to fully understand
the candyman conclusion
[Music]
don't say that as the urban legend of
candyman goes if you say his name five
times in a mirror he will appear to kill
you in 1992 the seemingly silly legend
set the stage for a complex film about
race and local mythology in the cabrini
green housing project in chicago years
later in real life and in the candyman
universe the housing project has been
demolished and replaced by luxury condos
this is how 2021's candyman begins as a
movie about gentrification anthony and
brianna are a black couple who move into
a newly rehabilitated building anthony
is a painter in an artistic rut until he
finds inspiration in the legend of
candyman he learns about the community
folklore from william burke a local who
was a child during the events of the
original film burke tells anthony the
story of police murdering a black
resident whom they believed to be giving
candy with razor blades inside to local
children as anthony starts to create
arts inspired by the legend of candyman
in the history of racial violence at
cabrini green prominent figures in the
chicago art world begin getting brutally
murdered the tension ratchets up after a
seemingly innocuous bee sting leads
anthony's hand to start decomposing into
a burnt fleshy monstrosity he grows
increasingly reclusive and distance
gathers between him and brianna
slowly anthony begins to see his
reflection for what it really is and
realizes that he is becoming the
candyman
at one point in the final act anthony
visits his mother in another smart
casting decision the movie brings back
vanessa williams as anne-marie creating
a greater sense of continuity with the
original as burke explains earlier in
the film during the events of the
original movie a woman's child was
kidnapped by the candyman and rescued by
helen lyle who lost her life in the
process
any fan of the 1992 cult classic will
recognize williams as that child's
mother the child then was anthony
himself anne-marie then explains to
anthony that when he returned she knew
somehow that he was destined to be the
next candyman in an attempt to have him
grow up normally she sheltered him from
all mention of the legend but it was all
for nothing his transformation begins
immediately after he attempts to summon
the murderous figure for the first time
it's not explained extremely well but it
seems that saying the phrase five times
in the mirror acts not just as a way for
the average person to summon candyman
but as an activation for anthony to
become him
[Music]
whatever happened when he was kidnapped
passed on the candyman gene though
that's technically not how the lord
works in the past the violent killing of
a black man would often lead to a slew
of candyman murders in anne marie's
explanation it's unclear if there are
therefore multiple candyman with
separate origins or if they all fuse
into one supernatural entity
william burke is the most mysterious
character in candyman and it can be hard
to determine his motivations so let's
back up quickly and recap burke's
importance in the movie prior to the
climax the last we see of anthony is him
returning to the abandoned neighborhood
where he first discovered the art
depicting candyman when brianna goes in
the laundromat to ask burke where he
might be she is knocked unconscious and
brought to an empty church where she
finds anthony's entire body nearly
succumbed to rot brianna escapes burke's
nightmare church to a house that looks
eerily familiar eagle-eyed viewers will
recognize it from earlier in the film as
the first place anthony sees any mention
of candyman
burke's history which is inextricably
linked to anthony's discovery of and
evolution into candyman is explained
through flashbacks that occur
sporadically as a kid he watched sherman
fields a local man who had a hook for a
hand get murdered by police he later saw
fields come back as candyman this
flashback confirms burke's genuine
belief in the legend burke also knew
that anthony was the baby candyman had
kidnapped and he waited patiently for
decades to help him complete his
transformation
in the final moments of the film several
white police officers invade the house
and arrest briana as she shoots and
kills burke anthony's corpse lies next
to his as brianna is forcefully escorted
to the back of a cop car she is
threatened by the cop in the driver's
seat and promises to tell him everything
if he can grant her one strange request
she wants to see herself in the mirror
brianna then summons candyman which
seems like an insane decision but if we
follow the logic that anthony is the new
candyman it helps explain why she calls
upon a murderous ghost in a moment of
crisis she's actually summoning her
boyfriend anthony for help but there is
also one clear thematic reason behind
her choice while candyman has a history
in the series of slaying people
indiscriminately that's starting to
change in the 2021 movie in the evolving
candyman universe the symbolic figure is
beginning to become a vengeful answer to
white violence and a protector of the
black community the framing of the
legend is the hero instead of the
monster adds a powerful layer of
commentary to the final scene of anthony
as candyman brutally executing a group
of white cops
so he's a candy man ain't he
the abrupt and cryptic ending to
candyman comes with a final twist that
might shed light on how the myth works
during his final rampage we see anthony
finally embracing his role as candyman
as his face becomes slowly engulfed by
bees anthony kills the final police
officer the bees start to dissipate as
he walks toward briana revealing that
anthony has been absorbed and consumed
by candyman the final shot of the movie
is of actor tony todd's face which has
replaced anthony's as he growls a
closing line
new to the neighborhood
the final line is a competent mission
statement one that is more meta-textual
than anything candyman is back and
possibly here to stay but the scene also
marks the fulfillment of anthony's
destiny to be won with candyman as he's
consumed by the bees he becomes like
sherman fields and every other candyman
before him more than just a man he
becomes part of the symbol that is
candyman represented by daniel robinty
the original candyman who lore says
arose in the 1800s the final shot of
todd is a great homage to the original
but is it a final homage it leaves us
wondering where the franchise can go
from here and whether that emphatic but
cryptic proclamation at the very end is
todd passing the torch or saying he is
here to stay for another trilogy
not to crush your hopes for a candyman
cinematic universe but there are no
current plans for a sequel to the 2021
film however the ending of candyman does
feel an awful lot like a setup for
another movie the abruptness of the
ending shot plays much better as a
teaser for sequel than a rap on the
events of this movie and looking at the
whole movie symbolically things begin to
click into place it acts as a passing of
the torch from robin tied anthony todd
is in his 60s now so it makes sense to
use this movie as a ceremonial transfer
of the candyman title hopefully this
means we get a sequel to this new
candyman with yaya abdulmatine wielding
that hook to bloody effect of course
it's always a treat to see tony todd
even in those terrible 90s sequels but
if candyman wants to thrive as a
franchise it may be time to let go of
the past and pivot to a new candyman
say
his name
candyman
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite horror movies and tv shows
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]